what's up guys this is eric griffin and
i want to give a big
shout out to helix sleep take their two
minute sleep quiz and they'll match you
to the mattress that will give you the
best
sleep of your life find your perfect
mattress at helix helixsleep.com
griffin
okay let's go
ladies and gentlemen welcome back
to your favorite podcast
what's up everybody ladies and gentlemen
this is eric griffin and i really
appreciate you guys watching the podcast
every week
all you new people all you old people
all the people that you know you don't
know what the hell is going on when you
see this uh the crazy guy from
workaholics or whatever movie you or
whatever thing you saw me on
but here we are once again trying to do
this
uh so i'm back again uh this is a
completely solo episode just me
uh i've been i've had rachel on a few
times and i'm gonna continue to have her
on but i just said you know let's get
back to the roots and this is all about
[Music]
yeah we did it okay
so here we are guys back again
um what a week i still will have my
relationship update uh went on a double
date with uh rachel and her friend
amanda
uh they're both like you know they're
they they're they know each other for
modeling uh so that was great
uh we've never actually we haven't been
on a double date so you know
it's like we're safe everybody's got a
mask and we went to like downtown culver
city because it's like beautiful
they got a lot of outdoor seating stuff
over there but it was cool but
the strange thing about it is like so
amanda and rachel they
i guess they got similar taste in a
sense because amanda just got married
and her boyfriend
if you saw her and you saw him you would
not think they were together
then you see rachel you see i people
probably have the same thing
so like rachel's kind of not dressed up
but you know when girls go out she's got
a
nice jeans on whatever you know and then
i go i'm wearing shorts and a t-shirt
and then when we meet up with them it
was great
the dude miles is his name and he's like
a he's like a
hip-hop artist actually but you see he's
a white guy from idaho with a mullet and
he's like a
really cool dude and and so like he had
on shorts and a t-shirt and
and i saw him and i was like this is
great we're like a support group
like weird guys with hot chicks you know
it's like we're walking down the street
with them and it's like it looks so
funny because it looked like it like if
it looked like it was two odd guys like
following these two hot chicks and it
was just
funny but and then we took a great
picture like side by side like
they did a pose and then we did the same
pose there's a picture right there for
you guys so
that was that was fun so it was actually
fun to like uh
you know go out and interact with people
which we haven't done in a long time
you know so that was fun so that's just
a short relationship update
hey guys i'm here once again to talk to
you about helix sleep they got the best
mattresses in town
are you having trouble sleeping you got
some old saggy mattress you have some
old hand-me-down mattress you don't even
know where you got your mattress from is
it the mattress from your childhood
listen you're an adult now it's time for
you to get a big boy mattress
get your big girl mattress and you're
gonna get it from helix sleep
i mean i understand right now it's
trouble we live in troubled times we got
this pandemic on our mind we got
politics we got so many things distress
and anxiety we don't know when we're
gonna
go back to work we don't know if we're
gonna go be able to sit inside
restaurants so
you need sleep sleep is one of the most
important things for
good physical and mental health
helix sleep knows this helix sleep has
this uh two minute quiz all right it's
perfect it's great
i took it i haven't got my mattress yet
but i took the quiz
and i'm excited for it and i'll be
talking about it even more in future
episodes
but helix sleep has a quiz that takes
just two minutes to complete and matches
your body type and sleep preference to
the perfect mattress
for you look everybody's unique right we
all got different body shapes and sizes
we all sleep different and helix knows
this
so they have several different mattress
models to choose from look they got soft
they got medium they got
firm they got mattress that's great for
cooling you down or if you sleep hot
or even if you are a plus size person
they have mattresses for you too they
got mattresses for everybody so i'm
super excited i love the quiz portion of
it i've never even done that before you
know you go to the mattress store and
you're like you go hey can i lay down on
this
and you're kind of like sitting there
and you're like huh how is this
different from any other mattress you
don't know
but helix takes that into account and
they customize the mattress for you you
take the sleep quiz look i took the quiz
and i can't wait for my mattress to come
alright
i got medium because i sleep on my side
and my shoulders hurt so
it's going to be soft i run hot so it's
going to be cool
i'm really excited for it and i really
highly recommend you guys go to helix
sleep because
everything i've read about it everything
i see about it this is a place to go to
get the best
mattress in town in your town in any
town because you can order it
right to your home all right this is
very important just go to helixsleep.com
griffin that's important once again go
to helixsleep.com
griffin take their two minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to the customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners
at helixsleep.com griffin
hey guys take advantage of this and go
get
the best sleep of your life let's get
back to the show
update but i wanted to talk briefly
about some stuff that's going on right
now in the world
a lot of stuff going on in the world
guys but let's start with the light
stuff first like um
not even light like you know nba you
know i haven't talked about the nba i
haven't talked about my damn clippers
choking away the series you know what's
funny is because
at first i know the clippers were one of
the people that did not want to play in
the bubble they didn't want to play but
they decided to
you know they you know they went with it
what everybody else did they didn't want
to play
and so you know so some people might use
it as an excuse well the clippers didn't
really want to be there well if that's
the case why
fire doc rivers you know they fired doc
rivers but doc
had his chance man doc had his chance so
i
you know he's the only coach that has
lost three separate times
having a 3-0 lead 3-1 lead in a series
and has lost the series
so you know i love doc rivers i thought
what he did for the clippers
organization and turning down around the
culture and all that was great
but at the same time it's like yo i felt
like we should have won a championship
back
when we had chris paul blake griffin and
deandre jordan
like we had a chance it's just we
weren't ready that
that year that we let it slip away
with houston i think we would have given
the golden state warriors a run for that
money that year that
we could we would have faced lebron
james in the championship but
we didn't take care of business and then
after that
that was our one true chance because
then after that
chris paul gets hurt blake griffin gets
hurt it's like
every other year was one of them getting
hurt and then it just never
coalesced into like a championship run
and then they broke the team up right
and so now you have this you know we get
kawhi leonard we get paul george
and we think oh man because first of all
i thought we could have done it with
just kawhi leonard with the team that we
had in place because last year the way
the clippers were playing
they were like because that that's what
doc does best
if you're a basketball fan this is what
and you know you know you watch
if you've been watching like dog rivers
is great with like
above average really good
like right there at the all-star level
players like maybe they don't make the
all-star and not because they're not
good enough there's just other better
players
but they got all star talent when you
give those kind of players to doc rivers
he will make them play hard play
together
and look like a really good team that's
ready to win the championship
but when he gets alpha dogs when he gets
out for dogs
something happens and they just do not
want to listen anymore
and i think that's been his problem he
only won
one championship with kevin garnett ray
allen and paul pierce
but and i think that was more about
those guys like kevin garnett being like
i'm not gonna lose i need to win a
championship for my legacy
and but even that year if you guys
remember
they went to seven games they went every
series in the finals was seven
first round seven games second round
seven games third round seven games and
the championship was seven games against
the lakers and they won
so i'm just saying it wasn't it was like
they barely got
that championship with doc rivers as
coach and then they never did it again
they got close but they didn't win it
again they got to another championship i
believe right they lost it yeah they
lost to the
yeah the lakers they played again but so
so he just he can't something about
alpha dogs
that they don't mesh with him
but he is great getting guys to play
together
work hard when they are trying to prove
something so i'm not surprised
but like i don't want to hear any
excuses like especially from like other
clipper fans
or even nba fans who are like oh this is
the bubble it's not the same
because they're actually they're
obviously treating it the same
because they fired him you don't fire a
guy
because i don't i don't think they
should have fired him under the
circumstances of a bubble
like you know they're in the bubble
we're in a pandemic this is not a
regular life
i think he deserved one more chance with
this group and if something bad would
happen then yeah you got to get out of
here but i still even understand why
they fired him so that's that
the poor clippers man and then you know
the other thing that's going on is
you know you got the the the lakers you
know so the lakers are in the
championship
and i'm not a laker fan but i'm a lebron
james fan i'd love to see lebron win
another championship but the dude is
damned if he does and he's damned if he
doesn't
because this is going to have an
asterisk on it which
to me this seems harder because
there's nobody hyping you up there's no
home court advantage there's no
big crowds of people giving you
adrenaline it's all about your own
personal will and fortitude
and there's no one better in the nba
right now than lebron james
at that his presence i don't know
listen i went to the laker game this
year and i was sitting maybe like
i don't know like maybe 10 to 15 feet
away from lebron james when he was
sitting on the bench
and you can't feel the dude's presence
the whole you can see
if you look around you see people not
even looking at the game they're just
staring at him to see what he's doing
the dude's got a presence and i think
that that presence in a gym
because that's where they're playing
they're playing in their [ __ ] gym
right that kind of presence
he just he's just gonna overpower people
like right now the series is tied 2-1
um surprised you know miami jimmy butler
went off
had a 40-point triple-double and that
guy's got a lot of heart he's the kind
of player that's the kind of player doc
rivers
uh he he's that kind of player i wish
jimmy butler when it came to the
clippers
but anyways so but i still think lebron
he's going to work it out
and he's just going to dominate you know
just his not just on the court
just the whole presence of it so even if
the lakers and clippers would have
played
the way paul george collapsed and and
his
mentality about you know all the things
that are going on and how it affected
him there's no way that he would have
been able to
have the wherewithal to overcome that
and push through and beat lebron james
but it's a shame we didn't get to see
that man it sucks
i wanted to see lakers clippers who
dominates la so it's like
the pandemic wins again man because
that's the only thing we were waiting
for and like and honestly like who wants
to see miami
lakers miami see even that series is
like
you know i would have preferred to see
boston but he wouldn't even know is in
the east just like whatever or even
giannis
like even that guy choked away like he's
been he got
taken out then he got injured so the
whole nba restart
i don't know i think i'd give it a
c-plus at this point right now but
you know again it is what it is so we'll
see uh
if by the time this comes out if the
lakers
will um have won the championship but
then like i say lebron is damned if he
does
damned if he doesn't which sucks so what
i mean by that is
if he didn't make it to the finals and
doesn't win the finals people would say
oh man you didn't make it to the finals
you didn't win see lebron you're not as
good as jordan and now you've gone to
your 10th finals and you didn't you know
you've lost six finals that's what
they'll say about him
but if he wins they're gonna say well
man it's in the bubble
it's an asterisk season you know so
the only thing he could do is this is
what's presented in front of him and
he's just got to do it
i mean the dude's great man i mean it's
no doubt i mean even
with what he's done so far in his career
even going to ten championships
regardless like regardless of losing
going to 10 championships eight in a row
he already has a case for being the
greatest player ever
you can legitimately make a case for him
and it's like and there's no one else
you know kareem is probably right there
you know there's no one else that can
have that kind of case with
his longevity of he's played and the
greatness level that he's played at
for so long it's unbelievable so
kudos to him and kudos to the lakers if
they if they win the championship but
you know it is what it is so that's how
i feel about my uh
that's my clippers update i'm sad i
don't know if i'm getting season tickets
again
because like listen with the pandemic
that stuck is expensive it was like the
one luxury item i i
i bought with like saved up tv money and
but i i haven't been on a show and all
that so i'm like
and they trying to they really trying to
price gouge now that they got kawhi
leonard and paul george but who knows
even what the team's gonna look like or
and then they're trying to build a
stadium so i'm gonna be watching from
home
whenever the season starts but who even
knows how they're gonna do it
they keep calling me talking about hey
we're gonna have we're planning on
having
people in the stands uh next season
starting in uh december or wherever it
is but
i just don't see how that's gonna happen
but anyway that's my mba update you know
i love the nba i hope you
you guys watch i mean just you know
watch there's what else you got to watch
uh
i'm i'm not listen i don't get paid by
the nba i just i just love watching nba
basketball
and it's just i you know it's just
unfortunate that
this particular time what's going on
right now how it is affecting the game
um but it is what it is but yeah
nba update
so other things going on in the world
last week on the podcast i was talking
about
i was talking about the nfl and how i
hadn't heard anything about the
coronavirus it seemed like it just they
just stopped talking about it
nfl started and everything was going
fine fantasy football leagues were going
on and like
you know the league started and it
started off you know looked weird at
first
you know no crowd but then they changed
the camera angles and they were doing it
and i just thought you know what they're
probably just going to ignore it we're
not going to hear
anything about the carnovirus and it's
just going to be what it is right excuse
me they cut to
you know a few days you know this past
week turns out that the tennessee
titans a bunch of players and staff and
personnel
tested positive for the coronavirus they
talk about it and now it's like
boom it's out there and it's totally
gonna affect the league
now cut to like baseball for instance
who is like in the middle of the
playoffs i don't watch baseball
i'm just i'm just not a baseball fan
it's really boring to me and it's just
like whatever
all right there's people out there that
love baseball more power to you
so they cancel like 40 plus games but
you didn't hear about it because no one
cares
besides no one's going to the games
there's no fans and you don't have to
worry about it
you just have you know
you could just postpone the game and you
could play two or three baseball games
in a day it's i guess
obviously it's not as taxing on the
human body as say basketball
or football is so they can just postpone
games move them around do whatever the
hell they want
if like players can't play they can wait
two weeks to do that game again it
doesn't even matter so
they didn't necessarily need to do a
bubble for a sport like baseball because
one honestly no one cares you know if it
came back or not i don't think it
affected anything at all
so but even that being said i mean i'm
sure
there is an effect because there's a lot
of jobs on the line
i mean first of all you know people that
work at stadiums they lost their jobs
and
you know you have i mean there's a huge
effect that uh this coronavirus has had
on the sports industry the same thing
with my industry you know comedy clubs
are closed theaters are closed you know
all that kind of stuff is closed it just
shuts everything down there's a
trickle-down effect
so but for the most part you know to
continue the sport right now
is basically just to make revenue for
the players and
the owners and provide entertainment for
the fans
on television because what else is it
doing because
you know they're not you know there's no
parking attendants there's no
there's no cashiers there's no
concession people
so who's this money being made for so
therefore to me
if if it's all about advertising dollars
and you making your money
through that way and like just you know
the sports packages that people buy on
cable then you make sure you put out a
damn good product
right so that's why to me
for instance with the nba and hockey
they went into a bubble
it's not just for the safety of the
players it's for the integrity of the
game
when we're watching the lakers and we're
watching the miami heat and lakers
playing each other we're watching we
know that
this they're they're full squads you
know we don't have to worry about oh we
find out somebody got sick and they have
to miss two weeks
and so now you know especially if it's a
star like imagine if lebron james got
coronavirus
like this would nullify everything we
don't want to see that so to
ensure the integrity of the game they
went into a bubble
it protects the players and staff and at
the same time also protects
what's really the most important part to
us the consumer the people watching the
people paying for nba package to people
buying
jerseys to people you know spending
advertising dollars
we want to make sure we get the best
product possible
no cut two you have the nfl like the nfl
they they didn't want to go in a bubble
they're like yeah we're not going to do
a bubble this we're just going to play
well you know the nfl the industries
that it supports other than like i said
the concessions people and all that
stuff so all
those people are gone they don't got to
pay any of those people it's done
and the same amount of revenue coming in
from you know the
tv and sponsors and commercials and all
that is still there
right so they're making more money
because but then again also they're
losing
on the money on the ticket the tickets
and season tickets and all this stuff
which i'm sure is a large amount of
money too
but i don't think it comes close to the
amount of money they make off television
revenue
all right so they decide but then
there's other industries like gambling
like gambling is huge in the nfl and in
uh fantasy sports
fantasy sports right okay so now you cut
to the nfl a sport that has to be played
once a week there's only 16 games every
game is super important
for the playoffs that lead to the super
bowl
they are not looking out for the
integrity of the game
you know because they didn't go into a
bubble
so now these players have gotten sick so
now
they have to postpone the game there's a
trickle-down effect for that
it messes up everybody's fantasy teams i
know some of you out there might be like
oh who cares about fantasy but
hey i've been in the same fantasy league
for like over 20 years now
it's a group of guys we've known each
other this long we've seen people
getting married we've seen kids we've
seen children grow we've seen like you
know
this it's a part of our lives it's you
know it's what we do it's
it's a fun enjoyable thing that we do
but it's contingent upon the nfl running
properly so now like you cut to this
week
like i got two players playing in that
patriots kansas city game
that now they can't play because cam
newton got the coronavirus
so cut to this is the whole point of
this now so now you know the nfl is like
well we don't need to do a bubble
whatever
you know we'll just deal yeah but how
are you going to deal with the starting
quarterback
of a of a game that is like a premier
game
it's a game we want to see we want to
see how this plays out
and now we're not getting the best
version of the game because
one of the people has coronavirus and
now they have to quarantine
and now what are you gonna do you're
gonna push that game back so how many
times are gonna push the season back
push the games back
how's that gonna affect like little
things like you know like the gambling
and and the gambling industry and how's
it gonna affect like people just
you know doing their fantasy football
fantasy football is huge you can say
what you want about it but it's actually
a huge
industry so like the nfl is not looking
out for one the safety of their players
that they keep talking about that you
know you go with the whole thing with
the concussions in the last five years
and they're continuously talking about
like all the concussions concussions
concussions and
safety of the players and making the
helmets different and yeah
less practice and all these all this
rigma role they keep talking about with
the safety of the players which
to me is all [ __ ] they were only
doing it because they got sued by the
players and they're just trying to look
out for themselves
but they don't care about the safety of
the players they care about money
so reason why they started it up again
whole reason why they were like so quiet
about coronavirus at first but there's
no way to be quiet about it now
so what are you supposed to do like like
if patrick mahomes gets sick
what are they gonna do they're gonna
shut the league down are they gonna be
like well we're just gonna
continue to go well at what point is
that to a detriment to the
integrity of the product that you're
putting out on the field i don't wanna
see replacement players play i don't
want to see the backup quarterback
i want to see the starting quarterback
the guys we root for the ones we want to
see on the field
that's the whole point of it so them not
going into a bubble i think is a huge
mistake
we already got enough a bunch of players
who have decided that they don't even
want to play
they did they just like there's like
eight players on the new england
patriots who were like yeah we're not
gonna play this
we're opting out of this season because
of the pandemic
so then now you got that and then you so
it's already like a little bit like ah
what's going on here but we move on
all the stars have started to play so
then now you cut to here's this game i
don't even know what they're going to do
as of today i don't know what they're
going to do
i think they moved the game i don't know
if cam newton's going to play
it's like who wants to see that and is
that how it's gonna be the whole season
how's that gonna affect the flow the
rhythm and flow of the
of this nfl season look we already
gotten used to not seeing fans in the
stands
i'm sure the players themselves have
gotten used to like having to like you
know
hype themselves up or some of the
stadiums in states that don't care
they're like are they
half capacity like 20 000 people in
there as opposed to 50 000 or people on
right on top of each other
so they decided to do that in some of
the states but it's like come on
like what do you what are you doing so
i don't know it's like
all over the country it's like we live
in three or four different countries
two or three different realities you
know there's some places who are like
hey we're just gonna we're open we're
sending our kids to school then there's
other places who are like ah we
shouldn't do this
you can't get proper information you
know
i don't know what's going on you know
what what is happening
so i think my opinion is you know i
think the nfl should have waited i think
they should have postponed the season
or they should have figured out some
sort of way to
keep the players quarantined you know
leading up to like leading up to the
season
but i guess it's hard to do that i mean
like the logistics of it sound crazy so
i mean the other
the other alternative is to do what
they're doing they just go hey we're
just gonna deal with it as it goes along
but at a certain point hopefully this is
just like a
outside situation this is what happened
there or they're gonna probably put out
some mandate and be like hey
can we make sure that you guys uh you
know have safer practices
can you make sure that people are not
you know
what do you call it uh hanging out with
people they're not supposed to hang out
with i mean i just think that the
players themselves need to take a bigger
responsibility
of this this product that
people spend a lot of money on and they
get paid
so much money for so i don't know what
you guys think but you can tell me in
the comments what you think about
you know what's happening with the nfl
if this is something that's going to be
do you still want to watch it i mean i
have some friends who are like they just
don't even want to watch sports right
now because it's just not
important to them anymore or or whatever
it is and you know what i'm honestly i'm
kind of one of those people i'm kind of
feeling that way too i i really realized
i'm just kind of like i haven't really
run to the tv i love watching the nba
like i said but
i haven't been running to the tv to like
turn it on and watch you know like i did
i wasn't like my clippers were on and i
didn't even want to watch some of the
games i prefer to
stream call of duty then um
play uh uh and then to watch um
watch watch the sports you know what i
mean so it's just
it's just weird times like how things
are affecting us
you know hold on a second guys
doing stuff right in the middle of it so
anyways
so that's my take on the nfl
and like i said in the comments tell me
what you think and
you know let's see uh how this how the
season plays out
right we'll see how the season plays out
so anyways other things in uh
going on in the world right now of
course the biggest thing in the whole
wide world is
uh our president mr president donald
trump
um
um god contracted the coronavirus you
know
so like i'm not a conspiracy theorist
kind of guy but i want to be one now
this is just
first of all coming off of just trump
talk all together this is
this is not necessarily political guys
right i know it's like it's weird it's a
podcast you know me
if you watch my podcast you know that i
i have my thoughts about things and
i love how people like they they assume
that it's like oh here we go with
politics
it's not like that i'm just giving my
opinion on like
the feeling of what's happening i'm you
know i'm giving my honest opinion like
nuanced opinion about what's happening
in the world okay
so first let's go back to the debate you
know we had this like
crazy debate between these two guys
and it just was like it was so bananas
you know it reminds me of like when you
look back at the debate between
uh hillary and and trump
because first of all you know
a lot of people you don't like trump i
get it you know it's like
he's he's such a weird dude he's like
hijacked
politics really you know i don't i don't
know if the
i don't believe that he's like
necessarily qualified to
be the president of the united states
from his background and what he was and
all the things that are going on like
you know
he was a business man he had all these
business interests he had all these
things it's like
you know go go do your business in
russia go have all these things you know
he became president and then it became a
conflict of interest of all these things
you know and he's like
i don't know why would you want that job
when you were like
people liked you more before you know
it's just weird to me why he'd even
want to be president i mean i don't know
who knows you know that's what the
movie like the governor made citizen
kane you know he talks about that he
says
you know when somebody becomes super
wealthy the next thing they want is
power so maybe
that's part of the thing you know the
allure of it right
but you know if you think about listen
put the politics aside for a second
trump's funny you know he's different
he's outside the box
i just think he took over the republican
party because it was easy
it was so easy just to hijack a party
that like has a
has a clear party line the right wing
the party line is very clear it's not
wishy-washy
it is this limited government we don't
like gays
we like our guns it's like you know it's
very it's very clear
what their thing is so it's easy to take
over something like that
it's not just kind of like wishy-washy
progressive
liberal you know politically correct
when it when they when it helps them out
you know
oh we like black people during elections
but don't do [ __ ]
after that you know it's like it's it's
harder to like for somebody to like
hijack the democratic party because it's
so
all over the place but the right it's
clear here's our message here's what we
want
boom you know so he takes it over
because
two years before that the guy easily
could have been a democrat if you listen
to what he was
talking about and saying he just he
decided hey i could take this over
very savvy you know he got a good people
around him ran
ran a solid campaign
whether it was uh whether it was honest
or not
is any politician honest you know i mean
with the guys you know the thing about
if i had if i had to pick if you had to
say please say something
one thing positive about the guy you
know i'm not saying the dude's honest
but i like how straightforward he could
be about
certain topics like for instance with
the taxes to do said i don't want to pay
taxes
so i took advantage of the loopholes in
the law
so i don't have to pay taxes these are
laws that are on the books
he's like hey the democrats so these are
the same laws that have been on the
books for eight years of clinton
eight years of obama the all the the
loopholes
and stuff that been going on for the
rich have been in place for a long time
they just change you know they alter a
little bit but they still
when it's all said and done it benefits
people who have money
and he's like i took advantage of that
what you hate me for it and it's like
i mean that's honest that's an
honest answer about the taxes none of us
want to pay taxes who want to pay taxes
when you go to your tax code you go hey
what can i write off how can i pay less
taxes that's the whole thing
so this guy just came out and said what
you you know we all feel
now should the president of the united
states should the leader of the nation
be saying that the sentiment of that is
is not cool
i get that because that's really what
that's about it's about like you know
you're
yes you took advantage of this we wish
you didn't take advantage of that
and let and made a good example by
paying your taxes
as the leader of the free world right
that's the feeling you have that i get
all that
but at the same time i also get the
other side of it who he's like hey man
yeah i didn't want to pay taxes
and he puts it on them hey how come you
democrats didn't take away these
loopholes
you know what i mean so it's like it's
like hey that kind of feeling is like
whatever
right so you cut to this debate
man what a what a [ __ ] show huh you know
you got
i think it was a strategy the guy
straight up
interrupted biden as many times as they
can
turn into a shouting match it turned
into like a weird thanksgiving dinner
like you know like two uncles
it's like two brothers from two sides of
a family that from the same side of the
family they hate each other they've
always hated each other but they still
gotta come together for thanksgiving
dinner every year and it always breaks
down into a fight
it just felt like that you know and it
just you know
like did biden come across as this savvy
politician who can handle himself in
tight situations
not at all he
came across as flustered and
angry and just you know
frustrated with the situation frustrated
with trump but trump
which by the way is totally
understandable
but again not as a presidential
candidate
like they both are not acting like
someone we go oh i want that guy
to be the representative to be the
leader this is a weird thing
i think it was a great strategy by trump
keep interrupting him get him flustered
you know you know you know what i mean
but isn't that ironic though
if hillary clinton had responded to
trump
in the way that biden did what are the
things we would have been saying about
her
you know like oh she's she's not fit
she's too emotional she's like well the
things we would have been saying so it's
just weird that you look at the
discrepancy between the two
not that she ran a great campaign
because she did like like one of
if i look to look back on that one of
the dumbest like this is
so stupid okay i'm just that it's the
dumbest
you're debating against someone and then
you're gonna say
hey go to my website to to do the fact
checking of everything this other guy's
saying
as if we can believe your website like
that was so stupid to me like she kept
saying that
the whole every debate uh go to my
website to fact check like wow who's
gonna fact check your fact checking you
know it just was like oh you're not
prepared for this this guy got you
flustered too this guy got you on the
run
sure enough the guy won not enough
people came out and voted and
she didn't go to the states she should
have gone to lost the election
now we cut to this now we're in these
weird times they had this weird debate
it was a debacle the moderator who's
been
the uh he's a great moderator right he
was flustered
it just turned into like they were
talking about stuff that
it wasn't even on this the subject they
didn't stay on subject they just kept
going and going and going it was like a
weird podcast that they were having
right now you know that they had right
so then coming off of that
oh and by the way this whole thing about
trump not denouncing white supremacy
which i don't understand
why he doesn't just definitively come
out and say something about that
and then the other side so you talk
about that and then someone says well
what about antifa
hey listen one it's not
opposite like that's the kind of
argument
privileged white people make when they
don't want to talk about
this one subject i've had this i
remember having an argument with a buddy
of mine a long time ago we're still
friends he's a white guy
you know and he was talk i was saying
well you know the black athlete is a
superior athlete
you know it's just the facts you know
it's not this ain't
this it's not a racial issue it's not a
racial just
this this the black athlete is just
superior
then he says well white people are
probably smarter than
like as if those were the opposite you
know because if you talk about one it
means the other no
they're not this is not the argument
it's not one or the other
you know you know what i mean it's like
when you start talking about
so if you start talking about why
doesn't trump just denounce white
supremacy
and if you say well how combined doesn't
i would say to you
yeah why doesn't biden say that but it
doesn't take away the fact
that trump is not saying the thing that
we all want him to say that makes sense
to say
all right the dude hijacks the
republican party
he basically says and does whatever he
wants
people love him for it his base loves
him for it
more power to him i remember seeing this
press conference that he it wasn't a
press conference it was a rally
this was after the election now he's won
he's out talking to his people
i wish i could find the footage for it
because it's great to me because
he says he's going you know they told me
that i should say drain the swamp
and i didn't like it he's he's saying
this to
his his base he's like yeah i don't like
that i didn't want to say it but you
know they told me i should say it
and so i said it he's basically telling
them
yo like i fooled you
like i just said what you wanted to hear
and and you too
you ate it up and here i am i'm your
president right
he's been this way for for a long time
after the kavanaugh hearings
he i saw an interview where he was
saying like
look i had to say those things he's
using these type of words he's like look
i had to say those things you know they
were coming after him and this is my guy
and i wanted him on so i had to say what
i had to say
he's very upfront and honest about like
yeah i'm i'm gonna say what i need to
say and do what i need to do
so why then what is the
the what is stopping him from being like
yeah i think white supremacy is wrong i
think these white supremacist groups are
you know inappropriate it's you know
it's bad like
he has nothing to lose he's already the
president he's already
rich he's already gonna parlay this
presidency into
more business opportunities and we're
all you know like
he has no one's over his head so why
doesn't he just say that it makes you go
well are you really racist
are you or is does somebody have a
videotape of you doing some [ __ ] you
don't want to get out
or like like you know what i mean like
what is what
why can't he say because
it would help him he would just could be
like hey yeah
uh white supremacy's bad and so is
antifa
you know what i'm saying he could come
out and be like both these things we
need to do something about
but to put one against the other or just
to not definitively say that
in these troubled times with the
george floyd with the police brutalities
being at the forefront
being talked about with the racial
divide in the country
for you not to just come out and just
make a definitive thing about like look
i'm the leader
i think this is wrong this isn't great i
know some of these people support me but
i don't support this
attitude i mean for him to be like well
i still need those people
is so damning even and i know there's
people that listen to my podcast that
are like
black uh people of color who are trump
supporters because they come on
my comments and they and they write a
bunch of nonsense all the time i don't
give [ __ ] i don't care
you know what i mean good for you i'm
glad you feel what you feel but
you know it's like you think that i'm
one of these like left-wing liberal
people that
no i'm having a nuanced discussion right
now i'm having a discussion like a
common sense discussion
i'm just saying like hey can we have a
rational discussion where we can discuss
both sides without it being so emotional
but these people that write on my page
and right they're so emotional and
[ __ ] stupid you know what i mean they
just they don't
want to have a discussion about like why
why didn't
this why does this guy say that why
can't he just say
definitively i don't like white
supremacy or
this is wrong why can't you just say
that it makes you think you know hey
what's going on right
so now anyways what we originally talked
about in the first place is then cut to
now the guy's got
covet he gets he gets coded after
everything that is he's
said about it and talked about it you
know you get it but see
i like i said i want to be a sam
tripoli's uh conspiracy theorist right
now
i'm not saying he don't got it but like
i wouldn't be surprised if he really
doesn't
because this is all people are talking
about no more talk about the polls
no more talk about the the the debate
in the future debates or what's coming
up there's no talk about
all they're talking about now is like oh
the guy's got this and how's he managing
it
and now it's all about how um they're
not giving us the proper information
when did he have it did he have it
before did he do things he wasn't
supposed to do when he had it
it's like that's all the discussion is
so what's so then you have all these
smug people like don lemon on cnn
so smug about it like just oh maybe now
it's just that holier and thou as if
as if now they think oh now trump's
going to get in he's going to come out
and be like you know what i was wrong
about coronavirus it's actually a
tremendous virus
and we should you know they listen
there's two things that can happen so
like i said if i was a conspiracy
theorist i would say
they're playing it up he's probably
maybe he's asymptomatic and or
he does it's not that serious and he's
going to recover
and all the liberals who are saying like
ahaha and they're making really
bad jokes distasteful jokes you know and
and i tweeted about it because i think
it's like okay here
i tweeted something i said here comes
all the distasteful jokes from the
people that claim to care about what's
right
listen that's the pc police so the pc
police people who are always bashing
comedy and telling us what we can and
cannot
say those are the same people who are
going to be making shitty jokes about
the president having coronavirus
listen i'm all for a good joke you got a
good joke you think something's funny
i'm all about it i'm pro joke but what
i'm saying is
you can't be the pc police talking [ __ ]
about comedy all the time
trying to put comedy away and then when
something sparks your interest
or something you feel like is benefiting
you now all of a sudden the shitty jokes
come out
you know what i mean oh now it's okay to
make jokes about anything
oh really so it's like no you're
hypocrites
you know those people are hypocrites
right and i'm not i'm not being pc
police i'm saying hey make your jokes
i'm just saying i'm just pointing out to
those people who were always
anti-comedy anti you know always trying
to like
what do you call it um you know censor
comedy
now these are the people that want to
come out and make jokes about the man
it's
it's very telling you know censorship
that's it's like that's what it
basically is
you know what i mean like now you don't
want to be that way anyways so
the conspiracy would be that he either
he don't really have it
or it's not that serious but you guys
think it's gonna oh it's gonna affect
him
what if he recovers like he recovers
great he's going to come out and be like
you see i recovered i'm looking at my
age and i recovered it's not that
serious i don't know why the economy
shut down let's start things back up
because look he's going to
lead the charge for that the only thing
that's really going to benefit you
people that like
one hate trump and are like super scared
about the coronavirus
you need to do to get super duper sick
you need him to be on death's door and
then he recovers
and then he'll then he'll have a
epiphany of like whoa
hey guys this is way more serious than i
thought let's uh
actually let's actually close some more
stuff down and let's you know hey you
read you
you uh republican states who open i need
you guys to close because this is really
serious
you know that's the only way
because when he just miraculously covers
in four or five days in a week and he
just he's back like hey i recovered from
that
that's only going to galvanize his base
it's only going to make he's
he's made himself he's got the sympathy
vote while you people were busy
making jokes and trying to be funny and
trying to prove some point
he's going to come out a hero and boom
reelect it that's just my the error
griffin conspiracy part
of the show you know i don't know
so i don't know if that even makes sense
it's just my
rambling stream of consciousness uh
episode of the
of podcast you know something else that
bugs me too by the way i thought about
this too is like
i read this thing about like you know
joe rogan who's my friend these people
that spotify or like
they're they're wanting to walk out they
wanted to like we're gonna walk out if
you don't let us
basically censor his podcast we need to
be able to edit his podcast
the the freaking privilege that these
people think they have
because this is what it's all about
right now this lets you know
how much money spotify makes okay
whatever the money amount of money that
they gave joe rogan
you know they reported at a hundred
million dollars even if they gave him
250 million dollars
spotify has over a hundred they have
over a hundred million subscribers okay
so
i'm just gonna say it's a hundred
million worldwide all right
that's nine dollars a month they get
that's and you know
so it's close to something like a
billion dollars a month
of revenue that comes in what the net
profits are i don't know
but what i'm saying is it's an amount of
money that that 250 million dollars that
they gave him
it means nothing to these people that
work there
they think of it as like well so what
well you know we paid him that so now we
get to do whatever we want
even though when they signed them the
stock prices went up
and it made them even more money so it
tells me
that they make so much money that they
are so entitled these people that work
there to think that oh
they can that they're that important
that it's like hey that's just a show
and we can just do whatever we want i
mean it's
crazy
by the way if they signed him to an
amount of money
that was equivalent like if it was like
a
huge investment for the company these
people would shut their mouths
because the people at the heads would be
like hey hey
this podcast is
bringing eyes and ears to our platform
and we need this money
it's because they don't need the money
these
entitled spoiled brats
think with their high paying salaries
they think hey
we we don't like that the guy is a free
thinking
that the guy has you know he lets
all different types of voices even ones
that you personally might disagree with
come on and debate with him come on and
talk with him that's that's the
free-flowing nature of the show
that's the reason why it's a success
it's the reason why because you can
watch it you can hate watch it if you
want
or you can watch it and you can say
yourself joe why would you put that guy
on your show and then another time you
could be like oh i really love that
that's the nature of it that's why it's
so big and it has to be
unfiltered and uncensored but these
people don't get it
because they live in their little
bubbles their little like
coastal bubbles you know they live in
their little big city bubbles where they
have no idea
no clue what the people in the middle of
the country are
feeling and thinking they make they make
so much money living in their little
with their teslas and and you know and
they're just you know
they they don't they don't know what
it's like to be a real person
so no i i hope that
he like i hope he just goes hey take the
money back
he wants you don't you think cause i'm
still gonna have my podcast on this
other thing and
i'm gonna do it exactly the way i want
to do and the same amount of people are
gonna watch it with or without you
like imagine the entitlement of the
people that work at spotify
to think that they have that kind of
control
it's crazy to me so my my my love goes
out to uh joe rogan and i hope that
you know i hope that i'm sure it's gonna
be fine because
he could just be like all right well
tell your dear up you know this is it is
what it is
this is like because like i'm sure they
could have paid him more money
i'm sure they could have said okay joe
we'll give you 500 million dollars but
we have to have
you know creative control and he
probably said
no so what's the amount of money
where i still have created control but
you get my
product that's the amount of money he
got
you know and it's more money it's
generational wealth
right and you know it is what it is so
we'll see what happens we'll see what
the
um you know what the future brings with
that but like i say uh my
my thoughts and prayers go out too not
that he needs it like that i'm saying it
like the dude's on his deathbed or
something no it's just
it's just it's just crazy to me when i
read that you know
all right what else is going on you know
you know what i love you know i talk
about 90 day fiance a lot i talk about
these type of shows
and the thing is people go why are you
watching these shows if you're so i love
it that's why i love it
i love that it inspires this type of
emotions out of me
you know i i i love it so much um
you know it's just i love to hate watch
stuff i love to hate watch big brother
i love to hate watching 90 day fiance i
love to hate watch all the
because of rachel i love hate watching
the beverly hills housewives shows
like like the beverly hill the beverly
like the housewives of beverly hills
with like denise richards who's a
monster
she's a monster and i love watching i
love seeing people
i love seeing people at their worst and
and making like ridiculous decisions
there's nothing better than sitting at
home
being like why why would you do that why
you know it's just i love feeling those
emotions it's like i don't have to think
about politics i don't have to think
about anything
important i could just sit here and just
have emotional feelings about this
so if you're wondering why i watch it
that's that's that's that's why i do it
guys all right
all right i want to go because i want to
talk about this
new the 90 day fiance uh the
the other way okay so none of the fiance
the other way there's like a new
um the new cast you know
season two and there's this girl i'm
trying to get her name right
you know let me just man come on
you know season two cast okay you know
i'm doing this like on the fly like i'm
on one man show
you know i should probably be more
prepared but you know it is what it is
um i just want to get their names
okay so you got like last week i talked
about yazan and britney
right but this one couple i want to talk
about is this one
arielle and been
been been been i don't know what his
name is
we'll just call him ben ariel and ben
okay she 28 he 29 he's a dancer
in ethiopia okay so they met while she
was in the i don't know if they met well
she was in ethiopia whatever
but they met they have a fling she gets
pregnant
okay and now she's and she lives in like
where's she from
she's from uh she's from princeton right
and she has this like super religious
like sort of religious family whatever
they have their religion i think they're
mormon i don't know if they're mormon or
whatever they are
and then he's in ethiopia and he's like
christian or whatever it is over there
because they're talking about the kid
getting baptized anyway
so she now is in love
with this guy you know the stupid things
that poor people do
for love is ridiculous to me to think
the concept that love comfort conquers
all listen to me people look at me right
now
it's stupid okay love
does not conquer all that's just the
movies
stop watching movies and thinking that
you're a movie star
or you're the star of some romantic
comedy love does not conquer all
okay it's the reason why divorce rate is
over 50 the reasons why people if you
if you're just getting married for love
i
feel sorry for you because there are
more things that go into making a
solid relationship than just love take
it from me trust me on this one okay
but anyways so so now she pregnant
don't even barely know the dude they had
this whirlwind romance right
so now she's in the states and she
decides i'm gonna move to ethiopia
okay and not only am i gonna move to
ethiopia i'm gonna have my baby
in ethiopia so the father can be present
right
and she's adamant about this her
family's telling her i don't know if she
do this her mother's a registered nurse
and it's telling her like
listen i don't know the medical
facilities going on what if there's
complications do they have the right
drugs
you know and first of all she's like
being condescending about
you know eat like as if ethiopia they
don't have proper doctors and that kind
of stuff
and you know what if i'm being honest i
felt that way too when i heard it
until they have an episode where the mom
and ariel go
to ethiopia and they go to this really
advanced hospital
and the people like yeah we got a nicu
we have everything that you would need
and it made me feel like huh i needed
like i had a i had a weird like
you know unfair feeling about the
ethiopian medical system
right that just because you know you
think ethiopia you think starving
villages you think you know
those commercials with flies are flying
around the little kids with the
bloated stomach that's what you think of
ethiopia you know so
so she so you know so her mom and her go
and all right so here's the problem
again
she thought oh i'm in love and she's so
stubborn like i'm moving to ethiopia
because i want to be with him and i love
him
now they show a picture of when they met
the dude's a dancer and he's a fighter
so he does like jiu-jitsu and all this
kind of stuff but he's a like a great
dancer
and he had like dreadlocks so
he was just kind of like nubian you know
exotic black dude from ethiopia that
this white woman was like
enamored with and let him you know get
her pregnant
you know maybe they didn't do it on
purpose first of all
i feel like the dude did it on purpose
okay quick backstory on him
he had another white american girlfriend
who he got pregnant and then they had a
bad relationship and
she took off with the kid and he can't
see his son right
so i kind of feel like he was like i
need to try this again and
i don't think you know you know what
you're doing you know when people say
like i don't know how i got pregnant
you don't know how you got pregnant
really you don't know how you got
pregnant
do i need do we need to go over it you
don't remember what happened and when it
happened you know exactly what's going
on
you know what's going on okay so i think
he knew exactly what he was doing
but as a guy you know when it's
happening because you thinking to
yourself like who hopes you don't get
pregnant i mean that's in the back of
your head
i don't know how many times you've been
in a situation and you're like oh this
feels so good
and then you just like maybe just a
little bit
it's this thought process again it's not
just me i know you're listening right
now like no that doesn't happen or some
girl like what no this happens guys you
know you
you just you it's just love that's that
feeling of love is right there so anyway
i feel like the guy got it he wanted to
get her pregnant but anyway
that's neither here nor there so now she
want to move to ethiopia now she gets to
ethiopia the dude cut his hair
all right now if you see somebody with
dreadlocks and they got like this nubian
sort of exotic look when they cut the
dreadlocks off they just a regular dude
he's just a regular nice dude right and
you could tell immediately she's like
oh i don't know if i'm attracted to you
as much as i was before
and i'm in ethiopia
you're not in princeton in new jersey
girl you now
in ethiopia okay she
he takes her to his place and by the way
even forget being in ethiopia
any dude that's living like a bachelor
when you bring a woman
over to your place most dudes the
woman's gonna be like
what in the hell is this and i'm talking
about in the united states
okay you think you fancy you know you
got
you got michael jordan posters on the
wall you got like
weird stuff in your place you got like
your men are so sentimental about
dumb things like yeah this is my jv this
you know
this is the wristband i wore my first jv
basketball game you got that sitting on
the mantelpiece
we have a lot of dumb stuff in our place
that when your girl finally comes over
she's gonna be like oh oh okay like my
rachel hates my couch
she hates my couch hates it with a
passion
it's that kind of stuff right now cut to
you in ethiopia
she gets to the place sees the apartment
the toilet
don't got a toilet seat go i'm just
gonna stop for a second so you can like
go ahead you hear what i said the toilet
don't got a toilet seat on it the place
look ridiculous if you especially if you
moving from the united like
if you're moving from the united states
and you have certain luxuries
and and and you have certain i wouldn't
call them luxuries these are just
standard things
just general principle you know you got
things in your kitchen like microwaves
and stoves and
and the kind of things you have that you
did we just take for granted
you go to ethiopia and this bachelor pad
dancer guy who works late
he dances all the time you know he don't
got a lot of money he got this little
shitty apartment
so you didn't you didn't think to like
have him take pictures or
or or think to yourself how about i go
visit see what it's like
now you just want to up and move so
that's part of it and i wonder too how
much of that is like the pressure of the
show itself
like are you pressured to be you know to
because now it's the show
so now she out here crying about like i
don't know anyone
i'm here by myself i don't know the
language
you know i don't know you don't know me
you don't get me
i don't know if we feel the same and i'm
like really [ __ ]
really so now common sense is going to
fly into the picture
so what do you barely know that you get
pregnant with
it lives in ethiopia that you haven't
seen in months you mean to say
that you don't know him and he don't
know you and maybe i shouldn't move to
ethiopia
really now you want to think about that
you idiot that's what these people are
idiots
it makes no damn sense why the hell
would you bring your pregnant ass to
ethiopia
to have a baby at some hospital you
don't know nobody
to have a baby but some dude you barely
know and now he ain't even the same guy
anymore because dude cut his damn
dreadlocks stupid
okay all right that's my
90-day
that's my that's my 90-day fiance
update for the week all right y'all
i didn't do uh real world advice from
from from a grown-ass man this week um
because i just felt like you know i
don't want to do it every week you know
you get like you might get
bored of it and we just want to you know
we want to like um
you know we want to what do you call it
uh you know mix it up a little bit
you know i might want to like do some
new segments or something like that you
know i'm trying to figure out
you know i'm trying to figure out how i
can keep expanding the show so i know
like rachel's a big hit and i am gonna
have rachel on the show more i actually
love having her on the show but she's
like so nervous still you know
like she's still like like she's you
know you guys don't know this but
sometimes we'll tape
and then she'll be like we got to do it
again you know and it's just like sad so
weird to me because i'm just like this
is a conversation it's got to be natural
and flowing and then she's like well
let's do it again
you know so then we end up doing again
and then she's like a little bit more
comfortable but then this comes weird
and she like
you know sometimes she looks like she's
like not listening or she has like dead
eyes or something you know what i mean
it's like it's weird so she's becoming
more comfortable so
as she gets more comfortable yeah we'll
have her on more and
and i i like having her on i think it's
a fun dynamic but you know again
i'm just i'm trying and i'm trying to be
comfortable with like
maybe i'm overcompensating for like her
being uncomfortable so then i'm coming
across as like however i'm coming across
so it's like it's just it's just weird
all right i'm trying to find i'm trying
to find this um
email i'm trying to find this email that
i got from someone
and this will be like
wait hold on a second you know we're
gonna go to it let me
let me rick glaspin this again right now
okay so i'm not i'm not doing real world
advice from a girl i'm saying but i did
get one question so and i felt like you
know what let me answer the question for
the guy
you know even though it's not for my
regular segment and i'll end an episode
with this he goes the guy says
i need some of that grown man advice
work is sending me to japan
i have to leave my long-term girlfriend
here i'm worried that
after a year to after a year or two
a year and a half that we agreed upon me
being there
that she will grow tired but i won't
want i won't want to leave i have the
option of being there for five years
it's eventually not worth risking a
healthy relationship
i mean it's he's weirdly worded because
i get it he was like typing fast or
whatever but you know it's one of these
things that you have to decide
for yourself what's important to you you
know
it depends like what stage of your life
you're in i think we all have gone
through this like you know if you have a
really great
opportunity for yourself like i remember
my one of my my
ex-girlfriend from a long time ago one
of my first real girlfriends i was in my
early early 20s and
you know she was like i i was early 20s
like 21 22 and she was just graduating
you know
she was uh you know she was 18
graduating high school and about to go
to
she had so she had the option to go to
like notre dame
she and then there was like a talk of
like she's like well
you know i mean i won't go but i don't
really think she really
was when i look back on it i don't think
she really would have done that
but just at the time i was thinking
about it and even then i thought to
myself are you kidding me you got to go
do that
i mean at a certain point what are your
priorities
and i'm always about like hey go have
the most and best experiences you can
you know like i don't you don't want to
regret that but at the same time you
might be somebody that believes in like
love you might
be somebody that's like you know hey i
think this is worth trying this and i'm
not going to have any regrets if i make
this choice
and i even say to that make sure then
that you give it your all
like if you're gonna not go to japan and
take this great opportunity because you
love this girl that you're that's here
then make sure you do it up big with her
because you just
because you don't want to regret not
going
and then you're going to resent her
because you didn't go
if if things aren't going in this
fairytale way that you want them to go
because then you're going to be like
damn i could have went to japan but i
stayed here for this
and that's gonna fester and grow and
it's gonna like eat away
you like a cancer so whatever you do
look because life life people
life is a series of choices
but it's not the choice that's important
it's how you live with that choice
it's like you make a choice
and a lot of people think that a lot of
people get stuck on
making a choice like i need to make this
i'm not sure what to do so they don't
make any choice so they procrastinate
no no the real test is making the choice
and living with it and dealing with it
because that's the measure of your
character
that's going to determine what kind of
person
you are and going to be so
if you decide i'm not going to go to
japan
because i have this healthy relationship
that is worth
fighting for worth not even just
fighting for not just even that the
right word
it's just worth cultivating even more
then you make sure you give that your
all
but at the same time if she's the one
and you guys feel this way then
why then you have to figure a way to
work it out where like
hey she wants you to go have these
experiences
so it's like a rock in a hard place it's
like how much do you care about this
person and their well-being
you know what i mean it's so it's really
a tough choice it's not an easy answer
but whatever you decide make sure you
give it your all because that's how i
feel about it you know so it's like
for instance it's like if you care about
someone you want the best for them
so if you find out that they're making a
choice that they're missing out on
something fantastic
because of you you for me
i care about that person so much i'm
like nah i'm
i'm out i'm getting out because i want
that person to live the best possible
life that they can
it might not be the right choice but
that's just my choice
you know so have a discussion really
talk about it
i don't know your feelings let her know
hey this is how i'm feeling about this i
really want to go do this thing but
damn it woman i love you there's got to
be a way to work that out
but if not be okay with the choice that
you make
live with it and live it live your best
life
all right guys that's another episode of
riffing with griffin and i really
appreciate you guys being here
i'm i'm building up to making a good
warzone episode because i play a lot of
call of duty war zone and there's so
many likes and dislikes i have on that
game that i'm gonna
get a future episode talk about that and
i might even
put release that on my uh youtube
channel eric griffin gaming
which you can see me daily on twitch
eric griffin gaming and i oftentimes put
put up videos after that on eric griffin
gaming on youtube
so catch me daily doing that and um
you know hey guys keep subscribing keep
liking keep sharing help me grow this
show
listen if you have some serious like
comments of ideas of like hey
eric i would love for you to talk about
this please put that in the comment
section like let me know like i'm
listen i'm trying to like i'm i'm ever
changing and expanding with you guys as
an
audience you know so sometimes you guys
like something sometimes you don't like
other things
i am still going to have guests on the
show too
but i'm not going to have them as
frequently as i did before
so is special so um
i appreciate uh i appreciate you guys as
we're going through this like pandemic
together
i'm still putting out content because i
realize this is who i am now i'm really
more comfortable with
what's happening right now i was getting
kind of sick of even doing the podcast i
didn't want to do it because i didn't
understand the purpose of it but i do
know now
i know there's people out there
listening i know i have an audience and
whether it be big or small
whoever it is i appreciate you guys you
regulars and all you new people that
have come in i appreciate you too
and let's keep growing together and i
appreciate that and this is eric griffin
signing off and i will see you
next week
you